here's a book that'll keep you busy for
a while the ultimate Alphabet by Mike
Wilkes 26 incredible images one for each
letter can you find all 102 things in
this image that begin with the letter j
well we've got Jesus we've got a
Jack-o-Lantern we've got the planet
Jupiter we've got a jet if you get
stumped and can't figure out what
something is well that is what the
annotated ultimate alphabet is for just
turn to the j page
here it is look at that it's not just a
Jet Plane oh no look number four what is
four the contrails coming out spelled j
in Morse code the contrails are J in
Morse code there are 1
234 things on this page that begin with
S at least one of my favorite bits is
the page for X what the heck is this a
red fish well let's look at the
annotated page it is an asterisk which
means it's a red herring there's a red
herring on the X page